yes all right stop it oh you go
okay so
is living forever a worthwhile and
oh
what the hell is going on here oh I I
think I know what this is Greg I'll take
care of it
What's Happening Here
unbelievable supposed to be working with
professionals here this never happens
when Joe Mackey's
oh
Jessie do you mind we're trying to do a
show
oh right sorry Joe guys take five
thanks anytime
these guys need all the help they can
get
well done so is living forever a
worthwhile Endeavor a Google nerd says
having to die is now absurd yeah former
engineer is predicting that mankind will
achieve functional immortality within
the next decade I guess that means he'll
never die a virgin
coming again nerds
yeah
but if we achieve immortality within the
next decade I thought that's when the
earth ends so where do we live
I guess we could all crash on Neptune's
couch
Ray Kurzweil says we'll soon have AIDS
reversing Nanobots tiny little machines
in our bodies that will repair it
damaged cells reverse aging and even
cure cancer and those will be followed
by Nanobots tiny robot grandmothers who
Supply your body with hard candies and
birthday checks for five dollars
Kurzweil has been right before in 1990
he predicted a computer would defeat the
world's greatest chess player within the
decade and it happened seven years later
and to add insult to injury the computer
then banged the chess player's wife
it's not possible
also wants to implant computers and
human brains to make us better he says
quote we're going to be funnier we're
going to be better at music we're going
to be sexier funny and sexier in my case
how is that even possible Right Emily
but does anybody really want to live
forever just spending five minutes with
Geraldo would cure that
sorry I don't like to insult Geraldo but
we've already met our quota for kill
Mead
all right Tyrus
what do you think of this would you do
you believe no why would he say that I
don't want to live forever no God no
take me no
um
well first of all if if this happened in
what do you say 2026 then the world will
be over in 2027. yes because now you
have a problem there's like 30 billion
of us and we're all living forever
somebody's got to go only Rich you know
what though it'll be the rich people and
then of course then the poor people will
come eat them yes so we'll have to end
the world as we know it yeah thank God
there'll be AI to clear it all up for us
tie it together so yeah you want to live
forever yeah no no don't you see anyone
see Highlander no there can only be one
immortality there can only be one I know
Kat you probably do but I want to pause
it why this is impossible because it's
going to put existential emphasis on
your daily on your daily movements right
because the only way for you to die
would be an accident so suddenly every
movement becomes Amplified so it's like
all of a sudden your life becomes like a
Faberge egg or a Hope Diamond you got to
keep it as safe because you mean just
like all of 2020 yes it was would become
just like a coveted clampdown because if
you live forever you don't want to step
outside and get hit by a hit by like I
don't know uh Emily
okay well she falls a lot from buildings
I mean I I guess I could always get hit
by a bus this now this regular way and
I'm still here yeah what if you've lived
forever and you survived the bus crash
then you're just a mess I want to live
forever but I like I also don't know why
because I'm not have like I'm not having
that much fun yeah
oh what are you guys no but you know
what the thing is you cannot you can't
you can't value life if there's no
ending the ending is what gives the life
value because that's how you enjoy it I
guess I don't know I don't really think
about the end all the time just like 80
of the time
um I think about your ending all the
time
Emily thought that was pretty funny
sorry I guess Emily does too all right
uh I I also don't really trust this guy
because he was like we're gonna put
computers in your brains to make you
better yeah I don't know how that would
make you better like in case your phone
dies like we already yeah we don't need
to do it you wouldn't have a phone
anymore
I mean I this is already implanted in my
hand right this has got more information
than the 1968 Space Program Emily how's
that for a fact the Mercury program ah
God I hate her
I hear what you're saying which is that
with immortality the stakes are so much
higher yes I totally hear what you're
saying however have we not learned
anything from Indiana Jones in the Last
Crusade Forever Young with Mel Gibson
and Twilight which is that it would be
the worst curse of all time it would be
the worst curse of all time to be old
forever and to have everyone you love
leave it would be so lonely they don't
leave because they're still alive
everybody's Barrett's like this isn't
fair dig us up dig us up take us up
that's a whole different movie yeah it
is a whole different movie but not like
we owe the dead to pull him out of the
ground and play with their DNA because
it's unfair to them but given the nature
of your life Joe yes you don't want to
live
no I don't and Cat made a good point
this guy was talking about putting an
implant into your brain for all the
special powers and I'm not up for not
after the 20 grand I dropped on the
other implant which was a complete waste
is the tooth it was a tooth in me uh
this is saying it's not that you want to
live forever you want to be young and
healthy forever you don't just because I
hear years 99 through 500 are kind of a
yes
it's a lot of relief Factor we're going
to run out
but the Nanobots keep you young yes so
they'll keep you but here's the thing
how the hell do you motivate a child
that's Immortal amen that you make
Command now I'm going to sit out 20
years Dad yes I'm not going to binge
watch Netflix for the next Century then
I'll do my chores yeah it's like it's
like do I have to change the Warren
Siobhan song I'll sleep with my kids yes
it's true there'll be no reason to when
does that kid leave home yeah when he's
300 years old yeah also this guy was
right once in 1990 why are we listening
to him we're right all the time
have so many kids because you wouldn't
have to raise them like they can't die
they'll never leave I'm right about the
ones that aren't leaving now but it's
like plants it's like you don't they're
like plants you don't have to water it
yeah what are you gonna do die humans
are like plastic plants you just like
let them roam around you kick them down
yeah you know what you can torture them
even because why not they live forever
if you had an Impulse for that
Jeff do his part yeah
you would never marry 2 000 years of
that oh Jesus all right we got to move
on hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else